Ahh.
Huh?
Nothing, I think.
I think.
Just Reston, yeah. I mean, we went to somewhere, but nothing really interesting.
Yeah.
Ohh.
But we pay, oh yes, we were, we are changing the face of the house now because it's, we bought the house one year and a half ago, but we haven't done anything in the house. So I was like, okay, let's start with this one that is a small, the small bathroom. So let's start with this one.
OK.
So it's supposed to be a small project, but now we are over a week and we are still doing things in the bathroom. So we're like, okay, we have to finish, otherwise we are going to change everything.
I.
I did.
To.
Sophia, do you also do like like shifting stuff in the house from one position to other, like shifting sofas from one room to another, beds, the location of the beds, so it feels like you know you are doing something and look things looks new to you in the same house.
Mhm.
It happens.
So.
My wife does it all the time.
Yes, I think this week or the last week, the last, yes, two weeks ago. So I was like, okay, I need plants in the house. I take my husband and my kid and we went to buy plants and we're like, okay, I want all of this. And I bought the plants and they were like, okay, so where do I have plants?
Yeah.
To put it now, so I need a place now, so we were looking for the place and we were looking hard to put this in the plant stands and do these and do that, like, OK, I like these now, but it took again two weeks to do it.
Okay.
So, what was what was your husband's reaction?
Oh, he knows me. We act together 15 years. He knows. He knows my mind. Natalie like, no, I don't like this. We need a picture here.
Okay.
Yeah.
Ash, ash being a husband, we know how we react, we cannot.
Hello, I just, I just wanted to know how things on the other side of the world are the same.
No, you just have to accept it with a smile and say, of course, let's do it. That's it.
Yeah.
Yeah. Happy, happy wife, happy life. That's it.
Great.
Ohh yeah, yeah, that this is this is the the positive code for the day.
True, true, so true.
Yes, yes, so 15 minutes, 15 years together, so he knows.
Yeah.
No.
Must be a beautiful journey. Hey, Tammy.
And we have Tammy joining in. Hey, Tammy, no worries.
Hi, sorry about that. I didn't get an alert. That was weird. Okay.
Yes.
Right, all right. We were just talking about how did your long weekend go. So Sophia said a lot, you know, what she did. So Tammy, since now you're the last one, so the ball is in your court now.
Today.
Yeah.
I, I first, I first at work.
But.
It was our year end, a month and a year end, so I we had to work.
I was supposed to take today off to compensate for me working on Monday. But I sort of forgot about it. So I'm at the office. I forgot about it. I made my lunch. It's okay. Yeah.
Okay.
Ohh, so you came to work?
Oh.
Hello!
But are you going to take Monday, Monday off?
That's dedication.
Monday, no, I have that appointment on Monday, so that's okay. No, it's okay. I'm okay.
Mm.
Oh, just busy, busy times go by so fast.
Okay.
Yes, it is.
All right, great. So thank you so much, Sophia and Tammy, for joining this call.
I would start with the appreciation, Sophia, that you filled in the CSAT survey for Sally. Really appreciate that.
Okay, tell me, did you also receive the CSAL survey for Krishna?
Oh yes, I have, but I haven't had a chance to look at it. I do apologize. I just didn't, yeah.
It's all right, please. Yeah. Thank you so much. Okay, let us quickly start with the agenda of today, focusing on the feedback for Sally and Krishna. So I'll first start with Sally. So Sophia, over to you.
Okay, so payment application goes well. We are working now on how to correctly apply the credits in QuickBooks. So we have to a lot of credits and I show her today how to do it.
correctly because I need that this is accurate. So she has to go and check to which invoice she has to apply and not just apply to apply. So we went through that and I also find out that actually we need more help from Sally.
because now we have a lot of clients, a lot of payments, and as I'm not doing the payments, I lose control kind of everything from the clients. Same with Natalie. So we need that that Sally is more proactive in that way, that she say, hey, we have this issue with this client.
Yeah.
They are not paying the outstanding, but they are paying the recurring or they are not, they are overpaying or underpaying invoices. So she has to be our eyes with the clients in this part of the payment and let us know the issues that we are having with the clients. Otherwise, we are going to lose control again with the clients.
Yep, yep. Is this something that we foresee that is about to happen in upcoming weeks or is it already happening?
Mhm.
It's already happening. So I talked with Sally today. We have like a plan. I think that we are going to try for next week. Let's see if that works, if it's good with that. Otherwise we have to implement something else, but she needs to be our eyes on all of this.
OK.
Right, great. Anything good that Sally did in the past week?
Um...
Same as the last week payment application was correct. She's doing the checking the tickets, but still, we are still having some issues with the tickets that she forget to close the payment promises and she has to go back and double check. So that is a loss of time.
Okay.
if you have to do twice or three times for the same thing. But she's working, she's improving, so we're fine with that.
Right, great. Thank you so much, Sophia, for sharing the feedback. Yep, Tammy, over to you for Krishna.
Okay, so Krishna came back from her vacation. So the first couple of days she was catching up on her emails.
And then she did the AP payments.
Um, took or two days, uh, and then today she's working on the vendor board, um.
I asked her to make sure that the vendor responds with a statement, that she reviews the vendor statement, make sure that I receive any invoices or update them on payment information.
So she did one with Ingram. But I was surprised with her response. It's not what I wanted.
We had a statement of account. There were old invoices and current invoices.
So I took a look at the vendor account in our QuickBooks, make sure that we have any invoices that we have or any invoices that are missing. So it's both. We have them, we're missing some.
So I didn't know she was going to reply. So I replied saying that, OK, I'm missing the first half of the list. Can you please forward me the invoice? And second half, we just issued payment this week.
And then separately, Krishna sent an email stating that all issue paint was issued this week. However, for the older invoice, can you look at your past history to see if the payment was made? Cool. That doesn't make sense. Response doesn't make sense to me.
So I didn't like that response. I didn't say anything to her, but I did not like that response.
Like she was, she made it on the...
Kip.
The like the vendors to.
Responsibility.
Hey, look, I made it. Yeah, yeah, exactly. But I did my research and it was in the system. So I don't know why we should make that comment.
To me, she actually didn't bother looking into the system to see if we had those invoices.
Just made it on them to say, hey, we made a payment, look into it. That's basically what she said, what she wrote.
Yeah. Thank you for drawing attention to it, Tammy. One thing you said that I wanted to ask about, you said you didn't make a comment to her, but you didn't think it was the right step. So why didn't you say anything to her?
Yeah.
I didn't say anything, no, yeah.
I just, I just need to think about.
This is the first time, first time though, so second time, I'll just gonna wait for the second response in another vendor is an issue, so I I don't know, like again, in the past, I don't know if when she worked with Ray before I came on board, is she ever did look into statements, so I don't know.
Okay.
Yes.
Yeah.
So that's my first experience with her.
Yeah, that.
Yeah, I was gonna say that's one of the things I wanna be.
consider it of, right? If there's a misstep taken, I appreciate the concept of like wanting to double check and consider what the right, you know, best way to tackle it is. But even if it's just happened once,
Yeah, yes.
Yes.
She doesn't understand what this process is, this simple, basic process of double-checking. Yeah, yeah, so...
Not true, no, true enough, no.
I.
That's what I want to do. Like I want to know, have a conversation with her, say, hey, this is, we need to look in the system. Like don't respond, like look in your system, see if it's paid or not. Look into our system, see if it's paid or not. Because I mean, the vendor did their statement by the payments and hey, look, we're missing.
Yeah.
And you just can't say, "Hey guys, you know I mean I don't have my system, that means clearing your system," but that's not the way to respond.
Right. Yeah, no, agreed. Yeah.
Again, so that.
No, that's good. Thank you. Yeah, I just want to make sure you, you know, from from our perspective, right? These are these are your team members that we we want to support in whatever ways we can.
Okay.
I.
Oh yeah, absolutely, no, and I agree, yes. This is my first encounter, so I mean, I will speak to her, but...
Yeah, but it...
Got it.
Okay.
I want to speak to her, but I want to take a step back and just how to address it. That's what I want to do. I don't, I don't, yeah, I don't want to just jump on it. I'm not, I'm not like that, no.
Perfect, perfectly fair.
No, heard and perfectly fair. I just wanted to make sure that it wasn't that you didn't have any concern about doing so regarding regarding our relationship with her, right? Because from our from our perspective, you know, we're here to support support logistics on the local side. We're here to support
Yeah.
S.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
challenges that you're seeing recurring trends of, and even have these types of conversations so that we can help you come to, hey, this is what's best. Yeah, but I don't want you feeling hampered, right? Or like you can't have that type of conversation. So I just wanted to make sure. Okay, good, good. Great.
I.
What? Sure.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, so yeah, so I want, I did want to bring up with you guys first before I speak to Krishna, so I mean, just let you know that this, I was a little surprised with that response.
Yeah.
And say, okay, let me speak to you guys. This happened yesterday, so it happened yesterday, yeah.
Okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah, that's fine. And, you know, we appreciate being in the loop, certainly. But this is your team member that we want, you know, I want to make sure you feel, you know, you've got the right level of control. We call the model that you guys are
Yes, it is.
Yeah.
Under.
The.
Yeah.
are working with us and called self-managed. It's because that gives you the opportunity to retain that control over that day-to-day management and that operational oversight. So I just, yeah, that's great. And again, more than happy. Beth, thank you.
Sure. Okay.
Oh yeah, no, yeah, absolutely. I want to get a conversation with you guys and then I'll approach Krishna.
Yeah.
Okay.
I have a question. What is the background of Sally?
I'm sorry, I didn't get too good.
Like working work appointment.
Yes, the studies or the experience that she has.
For that, I have to get in touch with the HR to get her resume because that information is not handy. But I strongly believe that she is a graduate and in the relevant field, of course. So, but I'll get those details and let you know.
Mhm.
Just a question, because I have seen that.
Maybe it's for lack of experience. That's some things for me is obvious, but for she, it does is not that obvious. So I'm just wondering if she has, she needs more help with because she doesn't have experience. So that was only the question.
The.
Okay.
Yeah, that's possible. And I think one of the things that's worth and what we can help with certainly on these discussions is if there's recurring sticking points, right? Or exceptions that are,
noteworthy and and should be actionable is talking about, you know. Okay, how do we? How do we heard that behavior? What portion of it are we capable or or
The.
not maybe not capable to have the bandwidth to support, because we certainly want to support where we can, especially if there's like recurring themes or something that would be like escalated. So if you're noticing trends of things, you can share them with us and we'll support. Again, like
Like we were saying with Tammy, though, I want to make sure that operationally you don't feel like blocked from being able to work in a manner where you're going to get faster outcomes because they're under your management, right? So, but yeah, we can get the resume and get that over to you. That's pretty
pretty simple ask. And that way you can have a little bit more context and background.
Yes.
Yeah.
I believe it was many who interviewed, perhaps if I'm not wrong.
You were there when Mary and Ray used to.
Yeah.
Fire.
I believe, no, it was at Ray if I'm not wrong.
Pre, OK.
Good.
All right.
I'm checking it with the bench team while we are talking to see in case if I can get the CV handy while we're discussing. I can share it right away.
Okay, great.
Any other questions, Tammy?
No, that's it. No, I'm okay.
Great. Sophia, anything from your side?
No, the things that we have talked in the last session is that that I need that Sally is more proactive in the in the task, but that's it.
We are working on that.
Rick.
Thank you so much. And when I was in connect with Sally, I think it was day before yesterday, there is this common shared file where I think everyone works and do the updates. So some of the updates were not.
uploaded on time because of which the relevant data was not visible to most of the people. And so this is just my observation and how I would want my team to work on that piece is like if we have a shared file with multiple people and all of them working on the same file at the same time.
So there is a possibility that you tend to miss a few things or if you know the connection of one of the persons is not stable, then though the changes are not uploaded in time or the file may crash. So just to avoid that in the near future, can we ask?
people to maybe download a local copy of the file, make the changes and then upload it.
No, no, no. The thing is that it's a shared document and we all work, we all need to work in the same file. So we don't use copies of that. And actually the issue that you are mentioning, it was on Friday that I upload and I see the transactions, the bank transactions.
Okay.
And I mentioned to Sally, hey, Sally, the bank transactions are not ready. Work on that because Tommy needs the information by 11, 12 to do a report. I left the office for two hours. And when I came back, Sally said, OK, well, the transactions are ready. Everything is done. So for me, that
I.
The.
that work was done on Tuesday when I checked the file, something happened with the file, the transactions were not on Friday. So she didn't work on Friday on bank transactions. And that is something that she should say something, say, hey, what happened with the file? There is no bank transactions.
what do I work on? Because nothing was, all the information was up to Thursday. So something happened when I uploaded the information that it was not visible for her. So she should say something. I'm not saying, I'm not seeing the information, what happens. So that was the.
Yeah.
The conversation that I had with Sally was like, if you don't see the information why you didn't say something.
You know, but it is the first time that happens, and I'm doing this fight for two years now, and it's the first time that happened.
So it's something that we need to work in communication. She needs to be more proactive, seeing this is the issue we need to handle, the issue that we have and solve it.
Yep, yep, I even, I, I also checked, yeah, sorry, go ahead.
But no, we cannot do answering, sorry, yes, sorry, answering your question, no, we cannot have copies of the file.
Yep, yep, because when I when I checked the version history of the of the very same file, I think whatever the the work that you did on Friday, so your name was not listed in the, yep, the name was on listed, so, so there was a I think Sally was assuming that whatever information she is seeing.
It was not there, no, it was not there.
is the only information that she has to see. So this could be a possibility. So what I can ask her is proactively reaching out to you towards the end of Friday, or maybe the days when she's working on this shared information so that if anything of that sort happens in the future, it is cross-verified and...
If information is not uploaded, then obviously you guys can catch up and re-upload it.
Yes, that is the thing. She needs to catch errors and mention those, you know. And she has been working alone for these two months, I think, March, two months alone, and she knows the number of transactions that received daily. So if she didn't receive one transaction one day,
Yeah.
Yep.
It's something that flags you and say, hey, this is a red flag. What happened here?
True.
Got it.
Thank you.
Any other questions, Sophia, you have or feedback for the engineers?
Sorry, for the associates.
No.
I said everything.
I, I keep calling them a genius because, no, I have a lot of ingenious under me, so I addressing analysts as ingenious. My apologies for that.
That's OK.
Okay, with that being said, I'll quickly share my screen. We can go to the presentation deck.
Please let me know once you're able to see it.
Yes.
Thank you. So this is our weekly business review starting from May 14th till May 20th. Starting with our agenda items for today, it remains same. We have check-in, we have highlights of the account, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of the customer, we followed and then recap.
We have already covered this one and I'll skip it.
And these are the highlights of the account, what we have discussed in the previous Connect, where Sally performance was reviewed positively. We also discussed about providing backend coaching and support for Sally. But feedback was to see where she was able to close 90 tickets during this period.
And for CSAT, we said the survey is going to reshade, and thank you so much, Sophia, for sharing the reset survey for Sally, and we are waiting time-based response for Kris.
Yeah, sorry. I apologize.
Oh, it's alright, just breathing out what we have here, so yeah.
Thank you.
This is the action tracker for the 36 to 90 days plan. I think it's so for relevance now. I can skip it one. We finalized the KPIs for the analysts and.
The scoring that we discussed in the previous connect for Krishna and Sally, so...
Can I expect us to get these numbers?
Sophia and Tammy.
So once I share this presentation deck in the email, would you be kind enough to, you know, upload the numbers there and share it with me over the email? That would be helpful in analyzing and scoring them for the relevant quarter.
Yeah.
Okay.
For sure.
Okay, I'll flag it, okay.
Yep.
Did you already sent this right? I think it is.
Yes, the last week email that also had this presentation, the presentation had this slide and a week prior as well. So I will send it with today's slide as well. So I would appreciate if you could please fill it for us.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes, for sure.
Ohh, yeah, yeah, I'll flag it. OK, I'll do it. OK, sorry about that. It's it's it was a it's a month and year end, so it's sort of bad timing, and plus we lost five days of we lost five days of QuickBooks too, so that's another thing, yeah.
Yeah.
This, this is, ohh yeah, I...
Yes.
I completely understand that. Yep, so no rush. It is just something that I'm counting on you guys to, you know, score the engineers internally.
Okay, yeah.
Okay, we go on to performance analysis. First we have Krishna, Tamila. So since she rejoined after her vacation, so the days that she worked is only three days, May 17th, May 20th, and May 21st. So
We have data until May 20th, where we have her worked on 39 vendor tickets processed during this time duration. Her productivity was concentrated on May 19th, where she contributed 70% of the total work that she did in those three days. So the same day was her week day as well, where she worked on 27 vendor port tickets.
And resolve and queries via emails and payment reports.
Any questions, Demi?
No, that's fine.
Thank you.
And we go on to Sally's data. This is for the duration May 14th till 20th, where Sally closed 101 tickets during this period. Out of which 63 were a QuickBook payment applications. So the six were ConnectQuest tickets, 10 queries resolved, and two credit card payments closed.
Her peak day was also May 19th, where she would resolve 61 items out of which 39 were good book payment applications, 31 were connect voice manage tickets, one query, plus 14 service board updates.
Sounds right.
And.
Yep.
And we have additional tasks as well, where she processed bank transactions, payment applications. She handled 19 non-ticket credit card payments. A few emails were also shared and completed two set of actions on May 20th as a part of both transaction support work.
Yeah, this is what we were able to capture on the basis of our connects with Sally and Krishna towards the end of the day and sort of put it here together for your review.
Mm-hmm.
Any questions?
No, seems correct.
Thank you.
Way forward, continue gradual increase in vendor board ticket volumes. This is so we are working with them already. Clear productivity benchmarks and track daily to close the speed gap and encourage subject node and enforce adherence to define workflows. So this is something that is in place already.
That's our team GPS slide. I can skip this one and that's the final one.
Any other feedback or suggestions, Sophia, Tammy, from your site?
Nope.
All good.
Yeah, I'm okay, yeah, for now.
Thank you. Sarbjeet, anything you want to add?
No, I believe you have already covered it up. Thank you once again, Sophia, Tammy, for sharing the valuable feedback. And we'll definitely work on the action items and ensure that we are keeping you posted.
Thank you.
Yeah, with that being said, I think we'll call it the meeting. Thank you so much for your time. I'll meet you on 29th of May. So until then, please take care of yourself and have a great weekend.
Yeah.
Yeah, you as well. OK, OK, bye.
You too. Enjoy the weekend. Bye.
QA.
Thank you, Sophia. Thank you, Tammy. Good luck.